♪ ♪
>> Greg: YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW
BAD COLLEGES HAVE BECOME?
TOP JOURNALISTS SAYING THEY WILL
NO LONGER REPORT ON THE NEWS IF
IT UPSETS ACTIVISTS.
"THE DAILY NORTHWESTERN," THE
NEWSPAPER FOR NORTHWESTERN,
PUBLISHED A HILARIOUS APOLOGY TO
ACTIVISTS AFTER COVERING A
SPEECH ON CAMPUS BY
JEFF SESSIONS.
ACTIVISTS FELT THE INVENTION BE
COVERED BECAUSE THEY PREFER
THEIR OPINIONS ONLY BE COVERED.
THE NEWSPAPER CAVED, APOLOGIZED
PATHETICALLY THAT FROM NOW ON
THEY WILL ONLY COVER STUFF THAT
DOESN'T HURT THEIR FEELINGS.
THINK ABOUT THAT, NEWSPAPER
APOLOGIZING FOR REPORTING THE
NEWS.
THAT IS LIKE A DENTIST
APOLOGIZING FOR FILLING A CAVITY
OR ME FOR FILLING YOU WITH SUCH
GREAT KNOWLEDGE.
IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE -- MIND
YOU, THE LOUDEST AND WORST KINDS
OF EXPRESSION, SOMETIMES EVEN
VIOLENCE COMES FROM THESE WIMPY
TWERP'S.
YET THEY DON'T SEE THEIR PSYCHIC
VIOLENCE DISARMING OTHER PEOPLE.
WHY IS THAT?
IT'S COLLEGE OF COURSE, ROTTING
FROM WITHIN.
WHILE THE PAPER PRETENDS TO
COVER NEWS, IT WILL BE THE NEWS
THAT THE ACTIVISTS APPROVE OF.
MEANING THE PAPER'S EDITORS,
THEY QUIT THEIR JOBS AND HANDED
OVER TO THE ACTIVISTS, WHICH MAY
BE A WHILE REAL JOURNALISM IS
DYING TO HEAR THAT IS A
STRESSFUL NEW STORY WHICH WILL
PROBABLY GO UNREPORTED, TOO.
DANA, THIS IS DISGUSTING BUT NOT
SURPRISING!
>> Dana: THINK ABOUT THAT,
YOU'VE COME TO EXPECT IT FROM
ALL ACROSS THE BOARD.
NORTHWESTERN.
I WOULD'VE LOVED TO HAVE GOTTEN
INTO NORTHWESTERN.
JOURNALISM SCHOOL.
>> Greg: WHERE IS IT?
>> Dana: IT'S IN CHICAGO.
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD BE MORE
SPECIFIC ABOUT THE TITLE.
NORTHWESTERN IS TOO VAGUE.
>> Dana: >> I THINK THATI
>> Dana: >> I THINK THATS
>> Dana: >> I THINK THATT
>> Dana: >> I THINK THATE
>> Dana: >> I THINK THATA
>> Dana: >> I THINK THATO
>> Dana: >> I THINK THATF
THE CITY.
>> Juan: IS ACTUALLY RIGHT
OUTSIDE IN THE SUBURBS.
>> Greg: THAT I'M ALREADY
AGAINST IT.
YOU ARE A JOURNALIST, THIS HAS
GOT TO GET UNDER YOUR SKIN A
LITTLE BIT.
>> Juan: OH, YEAH, I WROTE A
BOOK ABOUT THIS YEARS AGO, "THE
ASSAULT ON HONEST DEBATE" I JUST
WANT EVERYONE TO KNOW, PART OF
THIS IS ABOUT IMMIGRATION AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED OR
ILLEGAL ALIENS PROTESTING, AND
THEN SAYING, OH, MY PICTURE IS
IN THE PAPER, THEN I'M GOING
TO -- I.C.E. IS GOING TO CALL
AND THROW ME OUT.
>> Greg: THAT IS ON THEM FOR
BEING DUMB ENOUGH TO GET THEIR
PICTURE TAKEN.
>> Juan: OR IN THE CASE OF
HARVARD, HARVARD GOT INTO THIS
SITUATION AS WELL, THEY ARE
SAYING, WHY ARE YOU CALLING
I.C.E.?
WHY DO YOU GET INVOLVED WITH
THIS ORGANIZATION THAT WANTS TO
DEPORT MY GRANDMA, OR IS BUSTING
INTO SOMEBODY'S BUSINESS TO
THROW PEOPLE IN JAIL?
BUT AT THAT POINT, THE NEWS
TODAY FROM HARVARD WAS THAT THE
STUDENT GOVERNMENT AT HARVARD
SIDED WITH THE PROTESTERS
AGAINST THE NEWSPAPER.
AND THEY ARE SAYING, I CAN SEE
THAT THE PUBLIC POLITICAL
EXPRESSION OF PUBLIC SUPPORT
LIKE THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
SUPPORTING SANCTUARY CITIES, BUT
THAT IS NOT JOURNALISM.
JOURNALISM IS TO TELL THE STORY,
CALL PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES AND
GET AN ANSWER.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE POINT,
TOO.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE BEING CALLED.
HOW CAN A REPORTER DO THEIR JOB
IF THEY CAN'T CALL PEOPLE FOR A
QUOTE?
>> Dana: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER THE PHONE, YOU'RE NOT
OBLIGATED TO TALK TO REPORTERS
BECAUSE IT WILL BE ON THE PUBLIC
RECORD.
MOST ALARMING PART OF THE
EDITORIALIST TO SAY, OUR GOAL IS
TO DOCUMENT HISTORY AND SPREAD
INFORMATION.
NOTHING IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ENSURING THAT OUR FELLOW
STUDENTS FEEL SAFE.
>> Dana: THAT IS LITERALLY
WHAT THEY SAY IN CHINA.
WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT ANYTHING
THAT MAKES US UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU CAN'T COVER HONG KONG
PROTESTS IF YOU ARE LIVING IN
CHINA BECAUSE THAT MIGHT
DISPERSE          DISRUPT
THE SAFE LITTLE WORLD WE CREATED
FOR YOU.
>> Katie: AND IT MIGHT MAKE
YOU QUESTION THE WAY THINGS ARE.
I WANT TO APPLAUD THE DEAN FOR
THE ORIGINAL STORY THEY PRODUCED
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES, THE
UNIVERSITY ADMINISTRATORS CODDLE
THEM AND THAT DOESN'T HELP THEM
WHEN THEY GET OUT IN THE
REAL WORLD BUT THE PEOPLE WHO WR
REAL WORLD BUT THE PEOPLE WHO WT
REAL WORLD BUT THE PEOPLE WHO WE
THE SET OF ORIOLE ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO TRY TO GET
JOBS IN NEWSROOMS WHEN THEY GET
OUT OF COLLEGE AND THAT IS THE
STATE OF MEDIA TODAY.
>> Jesse: I THINK THIS EDITOR
HAS PROBABLY ALREADY BEEN HIRED
BY CNN.
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IS
JEFF SESSIONS IS TRAUMATIZING?
HE IS LIKE 5-FOOT LONG, DOESN'T
HAVE A JOB.
IT'S NOT LIKE HIS 9/11, YOU
DON'T GET TRAUMATIZED BY
JEFF SESSIONS.
THE ONLY PERSON TRAUMATIZED BY
JEFF SESSIONS IS TRUMP.
IF HE WAS ONLY RECUSED WE
WOULDN'T HAVE THE WITCH HUNT.
BUT I DO UNDERSTAND THE STUDENT
ANXIETY BY GETTING A PHONE CALL.
IF YOU ARE IN 1819 AND YOUR
PHONE RINGS, THAT IS TERRIFYING.
NO ONE CALLS YOU AT THAT AGE.
THAT IS EITHER YOUR PARENTS OR
BILL COLLECTOR.
PEOPLE DM AT THAT AGE.